[Music]
hallo YouTube just love us in our
friends
this is guns in here welcome to the 23rd
episode of my chest trap series this is
a special episode guys as I'm going to
show you one of my own invented trap in
nimzo-indian defense from the black
perspective the great thing about this
trap is it is very much forceful from
the opening and so far I have catch two
title players and few mm plus rated
players in this line in fact there are
only two feeder games played in this
line so you can literally use this as a
great surprise weapon in the tournament
the opening arises after the following
model d4 Knight to f6 c4 e6 and now the
typical limbs of Indian Defence arises
on the board after Knight to c3 and
Bishop to b4 by far the most popular
choice for white here is either to play
Queen to c2 or the movie 3 and in this
video we are going to concentrate on the
movie 3 which is known as rubenstein
variation well here black has tried many
options but I like the direct approach
and that start with Knight to e4 so
immediately black is attacking on c3 and
again the most popular choice from the
white is to play Queen to c2 not only
defending the c3 Knight but counter
attacking the e4 Knight okay here black
will continue with a fire protecting the
night and now White has tried this two
options amongst them f3 is a very bad
move the simple reason is after Queen
check the King cannot move as white we
lose the piece so by force white has to
play the move g3 and after Knight
captures g3 of course white cannot
recapture as the rook on the corner will
hang but white area is he wants to play
Queen to f2 and asking black
hey don't you blunder unite
well the answer is nope as Black has
this sneaky mu F fool protecting the
night and doesn't matter whether white
continue with a Knight to h3 or
ecaptions f4 after any of this move
black and simply retrieved the knight
back to the F Phi square same time
protecting the Queen and after Queen
captures and Knight captures well white
get his material back but look at the
pawn structure on the Kings side they
are completely shattered and in this
case black has a superior pawn advantage
in the endgame the more natural move in
this position is Bishop to d3 which in
fact double hit on e4 Knight and asking
black what you are going to do next
anybody who doesn't know this line can
easily play either the Moody Phi or
Knight capture c3 but imagine my
surprise black is going to continue with
b6 if now why doesn't capture the knight
then black will support with Bishop to
b7 so obvious choice for the right is to
capture this 9 and after F captures Evil
Queen captures 'if o is literally
bagging as not only white Vince the porn
but also attacking the rook on the a H
so what can be the more neutral than
this move well so far if you surprised
then you will be double surprised after
my next move castle on the Kings side
what a move ahahaha well it seems like
what is attacking the rook and black has
completely ignored it if at this point
white doesn't capture the rook in the
corner then black will simply continue
with d5 and for a pawn he get ample
compensation and I have attached a model
game in the PGN which will give you a
very good idea how to play such a
position with the initiative
the obvious question comes to your mind
well that's fine but what happens if
white just grab the rook in the corner
well so far I have played eight games
and in seven games all of my opponent
who are two thousand plus they have
immediately captured the rook thinking
that I have made a blunder and I think
that will be the case of many of your
opponent they will simply grab the rook
in the corner and thinks that there is
nothing is happening in this position
well guess what this is exactly black
ones as White has entered into the black
trap he camp the trapping business start
with Knight to c6 so black has achieved
the first step
trapping the Queen in the corner of the
ball here two moose has been obviously
tried and amongst them defy looks more
natural as it attacked the night and if
black moves the knight then Queen can
come out very easily with a whole rook
copper but in fact this is of big-time
plunder mu and many two thousand plus
rated upon and falling into this before
I show it to you what black has to do I
want you to pause this video and find
out a great continuation which gives
black of winning advantage okay then
let's start the first move is very
obvious we are going to capture on defy
and after white recapture we have this
star move Queen to f6 so it's a double
hit f2 pawn as well as on the c3 Knight
and the important point is white cannot
play Knight to f3 why well here comes to
answer black will play Bishop capture c3
of course white cannot recapture as the
rook on the even will hang
and ii mu Qing to f1 is not even
possible due to the simple thread Bishop
to e6
so by force what has to play King to d1
and as the King is already misplaced
black can continue his assault with
Knight to be four so the simple threat
is night to d3 and more pieces are
coming closer to the king but as the
knight moves away it is very obvious
that white queen can come out so isn't
that a bad move well of course not
in fact black has invited white queen to
come out and this has happened in one of
my game where my 2100 rated opponent
continued with Queen captures a7
thinking that I made a mistake and now
his queen is free but to his surprise
the game finished instantly as black has
this little move in this position Queen
to g6 once again a double hit but this
time it's more deadly as Queen to c2
straight away checkmating to white king
after a long thought my opponent
continues with Bishop to d2 which is in
fact the only saving resource but
nevertheless the game finished very
quickly after Queen check King - even
Bishop captures D to check Knight
captures d2 night to d3 check King to
have fun and now the simple move Queen
captures d2 and even though White has
three major pieces on the board
including the Queen he cannot stop the
devastation on f2
so it is very obvious here that white
cannot play Knight to f3
so only other good try for the yd is to
play f4 stopping any threat on f2 but
still black will continue with Bishop
capture c3 and this time around White
has an escape square King drift what I
found amazing about this position is
even though black two pieces are hanging
still why get losing position here black
will continue with Bishop to e6
attacking the Queen and White has
nothing better than capturing the rook
so at least white get two looks for the
Queen but after King captures a fade
Black has given a great choice too wide
you can take either of the piece and the
King will slip in the pad the first
option D capture c6 is obviously bare
due to the simple move Bishop captures
b2 obviously white cannot take the
bishop as the rook on the corner hang
with a check so White has to play a
route to be won but after Bishop
captures even black obtained or healthy
material as white cannot even touch that
Bishop due to the simple check and white
is going to lose more material and in
fact the game the more critical try by
white is to play B capture c3 but even
after this move white is not out of the
wood as black has this lethal reply
Knight to e5 so black is targeting
nothing but checkmating the White King
and White has hard time to dealing with
it one of our own game against 2200
rated opponent continues with Knight to
e2 I played Knight to g4 check and my
opponent played King to f3 well now the
task become very easy i simply capture
on e to keeping in mind that none of the
white piece has been developed
and after king cactus e two simple move
Queen captures c3 attacking the rook
Bishop to D to happen in the game I give
this check and after King to f3 a
tactical blow by black wind captures
defy giving up the night but in return
after this check not only getting the
material back let's say I continue with
g6 giving a check first and after King
to e find Queen captures d2 after the
whole sequence white king funnily placed
on e5 and black has this two passer
which is not easy to stop after fuse
black has easily converted the full
point so if you opponent plays d5
then disaster will literally stuck and
the game can be finished very quickly
more natural choice here for the white
is to continue with Knight to f3 but
even after this move black initiative
will run down on the board with Quint
web 6 castle on the King side and now
the star mu be shocked basics white
responses force white has to take the
rook and this time around black will
take with the crane the most amazing
part I found about this variation is
generally in nimes oh it is black who
give up the bishop pair but in this
variation the reverse happened as black
obtained the bishop pair and we get a
queen for two rooks but the most
important thing is the activity of black
piece are tremendous in this video here
black is attacking on c4 and white
should defend this pawn for example if
he doesn't care about this pawn and
routinely continue with a developing
moves such as Bishop to d2 then the
simplest is you take this pawn and after
rook goes somewhere let's say look to
even then black can simply play Bishop
to e7
and those lights good witnesses create
some nasty problems for the white camp
you might think hang on what happens
after a three well now the another root
might to AFI and you cannot hide those
lights curve weaknesses I have attached
a model game in the PGN which will give
you how easily black plays in these
positions so accordingly white needs to
defend the c4 pawn and there are two
ways what can do it the one way to
achieve is to play Knight to d2 which in
fact the course of my game against a
feed a master where here black and
continue with Bishop capture c3 and
after pawn capture c3 in the game I
continue with d5 and in fact one very
easily but later on I come to conclusion
that apart from defy queen to Fr is even
stronger as Queen is sliding in to those
weak light squares and later on you can
easily pick up some of the pawns on that
side anyways I have attached my game
against freedom master in the PGN which
will clearly show how difficult the
position is to play as a white probably
the most critical response here from the
white is to play Knight to B Phi not
only saving the c4 pawn but counter
tacking on c7 pawn nevertheless black
will continue with Knight to b5 now
taking on either of the pawn is a
big-time mistake as let's say after
Knight captures a7 black and simply play
Bishop capture c4 attacking the room and
after rook to d1 and Quinn to e8 the
night is a simply corner
so it is very obvious that here white
needs to protect the c4 pawn and this is
a course of my game against a 2300 rated
opponent where he continued with b3 a
natural move stopping any tactics on c4
and asking black now watch
okay then here comes the answer the
lethal blow c6 and white loses instantly
after this more if Knight captures a
seven then Queen to eight and Knight is
a goner if Knight and c7 then we have
Bishop to c8 and on the next turn we are
going to play Bishop to b6 and nabbing
that piece so the only good response
here for the white is to play a three
counter attacking the bishop and this is
what happened in my game but after the
simple continuation Bishop to e7 okay
white knight can escape on c3 but see
the cost as Knight captures b3 happen on
the ball attacking two piece rook to
beavin Bishop to c4 temple move rook to
even and it's time for the
simplification Knight captures even rook
captures even Bishop captures a3 and
after the whole sequence black obtains
to pass pawns and with the bishop pair
this combo turn out too much for the
white camper that's it guys I hope you
enjoy and learn one of my wonderful trap
invention in the nimzo-indian defense
remember that if your opponent plays
Queen captures a foe castle on the King
side allow him to capture the rook and
then get he'll lose with Knight to c6
and get some very nice victories in the
tournament well thank you for watching
this video feel free to like subscribe
and comment and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care
you